ladies and gentlemen thank you uh for
joining us tonight we have a very
special treat
again my favorite thing during these
times is when uh a guest comes here
in person very funny gentleman and a
friend of mine
has joined us tonight at the largo
theater i'm happy about this
it's always exciting when a friend comes
to visit yeah yeah
and and when joel comes too
my guest tonight calls himself an actor
and a comedian
what settle down his new movie happily
is out this friday please welcome
our good friend it's a legal thing
joel mchale joel you look fantastic
thanks for coming in person
oh what the [ __ ] oh come on that was
like four insults
no no no it was three insults okay
you're right yeah thank you
you look amazing and uh and and thank
you for being here
yeah i know i dressed up yeah i see that
and uh you decided to
on st patrick's day dressed like a a
british kernel
yeah no i am this is a uh this is the
only green i had
this is the only green shirt i had which
is fine and then
this is an old sweater that i found
and uh well i thought i had found it and
then a guy started yelling
at a restaurant that's my sweater but i
just kept it uh you don't really need to
wear green
on st patrick's day because you look
like uh
like some sort of crazy monster
leprechaun that lives underneath a
bridge
yeah well thank you for that you're
welcome um
but i felt it was my job my duty to
represent the good people
of ireland are you 100 i am 106
irish wow yeah it's uh i as i've
i've said i am dangerously inbred it's
been irish people
marrying irish people uh in america for
about 110 years that's and that's why
your eyes are like that
yeah yeah and it's why i can't see you
right now that's
i can't see you by the way the audience
is really
the audience is adding a lot to this
magical mixture it
looks like you've been kidnapped by
aliens and they
decide they were like he is a tv show
host make it his home
right on our planet like he has on his
planet yes
and they they put these two-dimensional
people there and when i say
two-dimensional i'm including andy
richter hey andy
hi guys who is that it's
joel mchale oh joel mchale how are you i
was in spy kids four
i remember no you don't okay yeah i
don't i don't
now is it true that you were only in spy
kids four because you were asked to
leave spy kids three is that true they
just
they slid you over one spy kid he hit he
hid in a bin
you showed up at spy kids three and you
went over to catering and you hid in a
casserole
and a casserole tray bin and that is why
you were in spy kids 4. it was a
screen actors guild standard stowaway
contract
that if you sign the addendum and you're
there you're in the sequel
you know even though my character was
killed in spy kids 3. uh yeah but you
came back and god bless you
um i want to thank you for being here st
patrick's day of all days
this is incredible you've got the green
shoes i have of course
the lovely uh green sweater oh what you
got there
uh we got some whiskey uh to drink very
nice uh would you like some yes i would
all right great
i will please ask your questions as i
prepare well first of all we know each
other quite well
off-screen we've had sex well if that's
what you want to call it
um but we are friends we are friends
even though i don't think we like each
other
oh we oh that's great wow
i'm already good i got my ice cream
thank you this will be mine
throw that uh one of your writers no no
this it's only on the floor
okay yeah no that'll be mine that'll be
right that's a three-day rule so uh
oh boy that our that went right yes we
are friends but don't like each other
but our wives
really make us our wives get along
here's what i know about you
yes you never bring out a product unless
you're getting paid
i i know you you and and so i haven't
even talked to you about this before
what is that maker's mark oh for god's
sake thank you it's the
bourbon of choice in my family uh-huh
yeah
yeah it's the 101 i didn't get these
glasses for free which pisses me off
can i answer your question i've never
met anybody in show business
who is more uh interested
in um in making a little something on
the side
with products that you genuinely love
but when you like a product
when you like a product joel mchale you
call the company and say i really like
your product
do you want me to do anything holding
your product and then can i have some
money and some of the product for free
true or false uh true and if the
they don't respond and don't want to
then i'd like i never liked it in the
first place
right uh so you contacted clearly
maker's mark
my uh hold on one second
oh that's the stuff wow that's very you
know what i'm not getting paid and i'll
say that's quite good
happy st patrick's day happy st
patrick's day going back yes i like
getting stuff for free because my
dad started that early on in my life
he he tried to procure things like if he
tried to return a pair of shoes and they
didn't have his size and he was like
well
you should just give me another pair for
free and often he got it
yeah my dad would also brag about these
things whenever he got some crazy deal
yep
when i started getting stuff for free my
dad would always he started going
you're just bragging yeah and then i'd
be like yes absolutely that's exactly
what i'm doing i'm bragging this is what
you did you taught you he taught you
yes i was like you should be proud all i
got i got them a free car at one point
and i feel i got look i'm not proud of
it but
i was like why not yeah they had to take
it back after 11 months
yeah that's fine that's not really
giving them a free car they were killed
in it
um
the important thing is you had a good
end to that story
uh i remember reading it were they in
the car when you returned it
yes oh he returned a charred car
that his parents were in uh and the fee
on that is going to be
huge when you explore this story it's
really dark when i got there i was like
this ford focus doesn't work at all
i demand another one
you know um let's get back to your
voracious need
to make money commercialize what i
consider to be art
uh so many celebrities now post
ads on social media yeah get a little
extra
you know do you know how much money you
could be making if you did that once in
a while
money's never quite interested me it's
why i live very humbly
what are you talking about you have a
movie theater in your house
that's not true what i did was is that
not true kevin hart
that is not heart heart sorry
that is not a movie theater you had
quite a bit to drink the last time you
were over
and you passed out and then i drove you
to a lowe's
and we watched a movie oh and then i
told you
yeah this is my movie theater and you
said this is incredible
and then you passed out again and i
drove you back to my house
you called me to help move you yeah andy
i was busy
andy dragged you he thought you were
dead for half an hour until
you started muttering i don't remember
any of this of course you don't you
drink a lot
you know what's nice we have a cardboard
audience and you're getting the same
number of laughs you get
when you're on the live show over the
years true there's been no
change in audience reaction well that's
why i'm having such a good time i can't
tell
i can tell and andy's awake it's so fun
andy's never seen a whole one of these
shows yeah you want some whiskey
yeah sure but later off camera so i can
really tell you how i feel
oh yeah okay uh joel it's clear to
everyone who knows you
that you have some kind of weird body
dysmorphia
you are you are constantly
constantly i've been over to your house
to visit your
you your wife and your lovely kids and
you are
constantly pumping iron and doing all
these exercises
um not necessary if you're a comedian
but you look fantastic i will say that
you got out and you look like
lou ferrigno uh you know after ignore
well i say for rig knew because that's
his actual name
people don't know that it is not his
actual name it is his actual name it's
foreign
uh as an n-e-u no no it's in it's it's
pronounced you because there's an umlaut
at the end
that's not yeah that's very true there's
no um italian he's an italian person
not italian common misconception is very
talented no listen let's get back to the
real point which is that
you feel the need to have this
massive body with lots of muscles
uh i could do that in an hour if i
wanted to
but i choose not to i don't well no we
can see that
my point is this go ahead settle down
sona
thank you sona i'm noticing whatever you
are
i'm noticing that in a lot of your
projects oh no
okay so lady i thought she was she's
right she's right there
see that woman right there i don't think
that no that's just the color
actually it has a cardboard cutout hi
sona um
cardboad she's the cutouts work harder
on the show
she's great come on zingaroo anyway um
i'm over here joel uh the point is i'm
drinking too much of the whiskey by the
way
i can tell you're actually starting to
amuse me oh
wait no so we can do this we can do this
look you're bursting out of your shirt i
can see it what are you talking about
because of uh i know i'm not why you
just sucked back in no i didn't
i didn't suck back in uh you're sucking
in right now nope not at all
this is not at all not sucking your
chest has grown
some uh it's you're like i'm lactating
you're like a bird
lactating see there we go okay so uh you
are
a man who's obsessed with having this
v-shaped uh incredible uh
adonis-like torso and i applaud you for
that now it
it occurs to me when i notice in your
different projects
you're always shirtless your shirtless
in scenes where you're getting money out
of an atm yeah
what's going on uh is that your request
or is that
well that particular scene my head had
been stolen
okay and i needed money to go buy
another shirt and but all the shirt
stores were closed
got it and that was the rest of the
movie uh yeah
i remember that dude where's my shirt oh
that was
it's great uh so i like to
i do like to exercise but my rule is six
hours a day
that's that's it no nothing else
uh i'm just going through i'm in a deep
uh midlife crisis holding on to because
i feel like i'm never going to die you
know what i mean
yeah well wait you no no no you you are
i'm i'm very impressed i think we're all
impressed you walked into the largo
theater today and
it was it's nuts you know you've got
muscles where i didn't know muscles
could exist
i didn't know you could have muscles you
have a ridge of muscles here
on your shoulder and then there's
another muscle that sits on top of that
the dorsamus left thermo and i didn't
even know that existed
yeah well that's just from doing dips uh
but
you do only biking right not true you
don't do a lot of weightlifting
there's no way you're emaciated you're
you're you're you you look like you've
escaped and haven't eaten for days which
is
yeah it's fine the look i'm going for uh
i'm looking for
civil war soldier that escaped uh
from andersonville uh which was the
prison compound where no one was fed
that's the look i'm going for how did
you pull that very specific fact
where which state is andersonville in
anton georgia anyway
so wait um i tried to get my wife to
visit
the site of andersonville shortly after
we were married because we were driving
through georgia wait this is real oh
this is true
i told liza if we drive three hours that
way we can go see a field
where everybody died of dysentery and
she said
i regret marrying you that's a true
story that's a true story unlike your
wild fabrications about you being a
money-grubbing creep but anyway um did
you go
she didn't let me go no i that's there's
nothing to see there see this is why
big empty field eliza and i think our
wives are much better than us
and sarah because they they talk sense
into us and
roll their eyes but let me get back to
your
because you work out every day no i work
out a couple days a week
i was kidding uh my rule is
45 minutes a day that's my rule and
there's no way you only work out 45 i
swear to you that's okay my rule uh
and if i because i listen to a book it's
usually dianetics and
i listen to it endlessly and then i feel
great then i'm ready to go
seven thousand years incredible uh but
thank you for saying that
about i i look i'm about to i'm gonna be
50 this year so i have to
i have to really sandbag because once
that hits
i mean look what's happened to jeff
jeff ross our producer who he's going to
kill i should point out
bravely served his country in the korean
war
and uh that was after graduate school
right yeah yep
he's uh he's 94. he's amazing he looks
incredible he's had a lot of work done
uh you really jeff you really do look
great andy where's your green
uh does just uh discharge count
and you wonder why we're languishing in
an empty theater
you know you're wondering you know what
the rule in show businesses gives the
people what they want
and my rule has always been no that
i want a sidekick who when you bring up
green says are you talking about my
discharge
that's what i've wanted that's what i
got and i've never been happier
and uh i'm in a with a cardboard
audience in an empty room how often i'm
here for you boss
wait how often have you happy saying
sandy thank you
how often of the words does discharge
count ever been put together
by andy quite a bit okay i learned all
of the worst
grossest things when i started up the
late night show it was like joining the
marines because the first person i
hired practically was andy and then he
has an encyclopedic knowledge of all the
most disgusting things in the world
which he proceeded to instruct and i was
my eyeballs fell out and then i was
i was initiated yeah did you know conan
you're the only television show that
i've written a letter to
when was that 19
no it was about a year after you started
94 probably no
73.
you know what we were this is we are we
were up against the sunny and share show
and i want to say that was tough that
was tough it was tough
they were they were at their peak yeah
you took them out
that was incredible i ended their career
pretty much uh
no i think it was right around the
it must have been 95 because i was
living in my parents home
right in college right and i laughed
alone so hard that i thought i was a
crazy person
no that's nice it was when you put a
bear on either side oh
yeah because you would found there was
an angel and a
bear a bear and an angel instead of an
angel and a devil it was an angel who
told me the good thing to do and then a
bear would show up on the other shoulder
yes and the bear didn't know what was
going on and the angel was frustrated it
was
it was actually a really funny bit it
was such a cause
i'm gonna tell i'm gonna explain a bit
to you that because this it never
left me because you had found a wallet
and had money inside
and you were conflicted whether you
should take money out of it and
the angel was like dude conan give the
get all back
that's what you should do and the bear
was like always maul with your front
paws yes
and you were like what kind of advice is
that yeah and then the devil
strolled into the shot with the bear and
the bear
mauled the devil to death and then the
angel began screaming
and i to the i was just like that thank
you i've never received that's so nice
that i really wrote a letter and put a
stamp on it
and this is back when you would do that
and i tied it to it that's really nice
a pigeon's leg and now when you say
that's really nice no no
you're like fine no no no i'm not i'm
actually uh
i'll risk being sincere for a second at
this stage no
i'm serious at this i don't know how you
feel andy but at this stage
in our silly long run of this thing of
almost 30 years
i'm just so happy when people i like who
are funny come up to me and say i was
five years old i was eight years old
that was nine years old that made me
laugh i think oh that's
that's like all i wanted that in real
estate and a lot of stocks
but that was all i really wanted so so
then why did you put all your money into
diamond futures
i thought it was the way to go i got
some bad advice yeah because it's
a rough business i did it very bad no no
i but i seriously
uh you know we always undercut those
things but it was i like that i like
hearing that
and um i don't know where to go from
here because it's weird to compliment
you
i know it's uncomfortable we have a
relationship where we do this the whole
time so now
i can just throw that on andy we have to
get to your project which is
uh do we really we really do it's called
oh
and then i was just regaling you again
on a
another i remember when i can't i know
you'll cut this out and i've made the
show longer but i remember when harrison
ford
was on your show it was at nbc
and he was promoting the widowmaker the
submarine show
and he said on air he goes i don't know
why they called the movie that
i mean why would you call the movie the
widow maker and then you were like
i had no i don't know uh but here you
are
talking about your movie that you're
promoting that you're
not and i was so happy no but he also
said
he he was obsessed harrison ford with
the fact that they had to do russian
accents
and he kept with disdain saying oh and
check out our russian accents
you've got to check out our because he's
such a harrison ford is such a funny
person
yes and doesn't care he's harrison ford
so he came on him from promoting the
movie and was basically saying yeah
i wouldn't watch it but knock yourself
out it was fantastic which just made
people go watch the movie i assume
nope uh oh okay now listen
shoot yes uh what size are your feet
nines
no these are these are twelves these are
these are twelves why would you say nine
when it's a twelve that's clearly a
large foot
no all right what do you mean no no i'm
i'm a 14. oh well that's too bad so
no marfan syndrome can't be treated
ask ask john tech once once
get that into a promo right away no
seriously once
i mean clearly uh clearly your pituitary
went crazy because of the disease
and you know but whatever you know what
like lurch on the addams family you got
a gig that's the important thing lurch
john tash when is the last time you've
asked john tesh
i have the johntech app the ass john
tash app but
uh uh when's the last time you talked to
john tash uh actually i ran into him
skiing
just a couple years ago we had a lovely
conversation that's true story how big
were his
feet smaller than mine let's move on
okay the movie you're promoting happily
yes uh let's talk about it again we have
a clip but before we do that
i understand that you have found ways to
be naked in this movie as well to show
off your findings i have
thank you for saying that yes why play
the husband
to the uh a lovely amazing actor named
carrie bache she's one of the best
actors i've ever worked with
i hope you have her on the show soon i'm
sure she's dying to be on this program
no we we play a married couple that have
sex three times a day and we've been
married 14 years ah
and you're doing science fiction now oh
come on
uh so we have a clip here from hapley uh
set up the clip for us won't you joel
uh yes so this clip i'm gonna set up
okay is i'm
i i'm not sure i think you guys are
about to go
you and your lovely wife are about to go
on a weekend getaway right
okay [ __ ]
because they usually uh yeah we're about
to go we are trying
that's right you usually care about a
show you're on no
no it's look i know i
i've i have i have no um i
wow i had some of this whiskey and no
this clip if i
i'm not gonna remember it right someone
has died and we're not sure if we're
we're pretty sure we're responsible so
we're trying to
figure out how to behave as if you've
just killed someone without
seeming out of place so got it we are
yes is that correct no no god damn it
no you just set up the wrong clip let's
throw to this clip
uh from happily and um all of this
america has to
america has to know and they will know
about you this is airing in america
oh man we think let's take a look at
this clip from happily
somebody is going to come looking for
him we don't know that
yes we do and i don't want to be here
when that happens
where do you want to go i don't know
anywhere i mean literally
anywhere oh my gosh
hi karen i just wanted to call and
apologize
i think we may have been a little harsh
last night thanks
look if you guys are so interested in
getting out of town for the weekend we'd
love for you to come on
that sounds great we would love to
perfect i'll text you the address in the
code for the front gate
amazing see you tomorrow
bye
is this a good idea you said anywhere
okay now i can explain the clip let's
hear this has
never been done we show the clip and
then you explain it uh
yeah because our friends because we have
so much sex
uh they hate us and they dis-invite us
to the weekend
away can you put this in the beginning
of the clip i'd rather you didn't they
they reinvite us because they feel bad
as you saw
that was the amazing natalie z and uh on
the phone but uh that
that's that's when we decided to go away
for the weekend with our friends
all right then everybody dies okay now
you just gave that away
did he have his shirt on i couldn't see
the clip what they did is they digitally
added a shirt afterwards
oh okay because they realize that he's
shirtless in every
single scene yeah good uh it's it's an
army green
shirt with like an army green sweater on
top
um all right we're gonna wrap this up
why well
you've alienated my audience and i think
your audience is paper
i know and they're not having it there
you have your uh sona's gone into labor
yeah you're you're the writer mike is
that him
uh that's matt matt mike yeah he's
like mike was the other guy yeah mike is
the other writer
i have two writers uh yes as depicted on
larry sanders you only need two
um uh when is the last time you watch
larry sanders
please another unproductive cul-de-sac
and i won't go down
i keep trying to drive this car to the
airport and you keep saying hey
there's an alley let's go down there at
90 miles an hour let's see what's there
i mean you might get something let's let
it go
the important thing to get out there one
thing first of all i want to say happily
is available this friday in theaters
digital
and video on demand and i also want to
mention
that when you drove you are constantly
wheeling and dealing because you are a
wheeler dealer
and true story he drives up in a very
nice car and rolls down the window and
we haven't seen
each other in a year and we've been
texting and talking and sexting and
whatever and
his his window comes down and and
and i said oh nice car and he said do
you want to buy it
and you weren't kidding you tried to
sell me your car
in the alley outside this theater
because you found another car you like
and you tried to sell it to me
i think it's a great car for you it's
not a great car
no no no you i know that you're a tall
man but it's a sports car it's
two-seater but it fits
right no one wastes time like you uh
you're a good man
it's a lot of fun
thank you thank you very much